I have an argument with a feminist and
she was saying that we need to teach men
not to rape and I said my dear I love
how idealistic you are but I am
realistic men are already taught not to
read she's like no they need to we need
to go and change language at school and
rewrite history and do all the [ __ ]
they're trying to do to make men weak
because they think that weak men don't
rape which is another argument I want to
come back to because weak men are the
most dangerous men on the planet let's
talk about that later
but I said no people already understand
that break is wrong unfortunately human
nature some people don't care about
doing wrong things we should teach
people not to steal but they still steal
would you agree that everyone says don't
steal the Bible says don't steal the
Quran says don't steal School say don't
steal everyone says don't steal people
still steal so if I were to take a
million dollars in cash and walk down
the street at night in the worst part of
town holding it to a degree I would have
some responsibility when I got robbed
the police would come and say why did
you do that people would say Andrew why
did you do that you have to protect
yourself from things you can't just rely
on the ideological hope that others
other people in the world are going to
be perfect and infallible or that the
law is going to prevent it you have to
say no I can't walk through the ghetto
at two in the morning with a million
dollars in cash I take personal
responsibility she agreed I said then by
extension would you agree that the
smartest single woman can do to prevent
rape is not to sit here on a podcast and
try and change the way men think and
talk about your [ __ ] but to take
some degree of personal responsibility
and not put yourself in dangerous
situations I'm not saying that's going
to prevent all rape I'm not saying that
rape is okay rapists should be executed
I'm not saying that every single woman
who was ever assaulted could have
prevented that I'm not saying any of
that I'm saying the smartest single
woman can do is say this is dangerous
going home with this guy I just met is
dangerous walking through this area and
by myself is dangerous let me call a
taxi let me call my brother let me go
with my husband the isn't that a more
intelligent way to teach women to
prevent themselves from being raped as
opposed to telling them you can do
whatever you want walk around the middle
of the night naked it's no problem men
shouldn't rape men of the problem I said
what you're trying to do is illogical
what I'm trying to say will actually
prevent rape so what you're saying when
you're telling girls do whatever you
want men are the problem you're
convincing women to put themselves in
situations where bad things might happen
to them whereas I'm saying listen woman
and men
look after yourselves I'm a full-grown
man four-time kickboxing world champion
there's places I don't go alone like I I
came here with security that's called
being intelligent adult so I this is
what I was trying to say I was trying to
say you need to women need to protect
themselves and bear some responsibility
to make sure they don't put themselves
in situations where bad things can
happen to them easily
I'd like to think that's a pretty
logical point now Andrew said rape's
fine Andrew said his women's fault I
didn't say that I I really didn't say
that it's completely insane if when if I
speak to my brother's daughter or when I
have daughters of my own and they say
I'm concerned how do I protect myself
I'm not going to say don't worry here's
how we're going to protect you I'm going
to rewrite the mentality of every man on
the planet so you can walk around naked
at night I'm gonna say listen you don't
go out at night you better I'll come
pick you up who are you going with
that's just intelligent I don't think
but they've taken it misconstrued it
taken completely out of context put it
on tick tocks purported it media machine
picked it up lied about me deleted me so
I can't defend myself and now I'm
dangerous to the world it's a [ __ ]
scam it's all a scam and it's actually
quite interesting because
the people who are close to me have said
to me in real time Andrew you've
impressed us I said how that goes the
hit piece they've done on you is
unprecedented in the world
and you seem unfazed it's like it's not
a matter of being unfazed it's slightly
annoying it's a matter of just analyzing
you know what I can actually do about it
but um I think most people who had been
through the [ __ ] I've been through right
now would be genuinely upset and
affected by it I don't give a [ __ ] right
because I've set my life up in a way
that I know I'm okay but not many people
can handle the entire world saying
you're a [ __ ] rape apologist and
we're gonna delete them from the entire
world he's dangerous to women a lot of
people are going to want that to happen
so what they've done is genuinely
criminal because this is [ __ ] I was
sticking up for women against feminist
saying don't tell women to go out at
night they're going to get hurt it's
absolutely absolutely saying and like
you correctly identified earlier if
someone were to hurt a female member of
my family give me the biggest mistake
they ever [ __ ] made
God I don't care about you know I'm the
worst I'm the worst enemy a man who
hurts a woman could be if you enjoyed
this video and you want to watch the
entire podcast click over here and if
you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as Kiyosaki Tate
Connolly parliamentary myself and others
download the app connect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the app minute and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
foreign
[Music]